All internship programs in the European Union,
their remuneration is compounded.
The 1st stage is the blue book,
it is 1 little the most famous and prestigious.
Uh,
it's 1 internship at the
European Commission
and he is paid between 1002 and €1.400
if I'm not mistaken.
Application periods,
they are always the same.
This is 1 course that opens twice a year,
1st period between February and March
and 1 second application period
which is open between July and August
for 1 course starting in March
or 1 internship that would start in October.
2nd stage of the Schumann coup,
is the internships at the European Parliament.
The application wig is 1 little off,
uh,
compared to the one in the blue book,
I think it's the end of May,
the 1st application period
for 1 course
which would therefore start in September or October.
And the second application period,
it is from October 1st to 31st
for 1 course starting in March,
3rd program,
and it is the one that not many people in
reality know,
it is the training courses to the deligations of the Union
European Union abroad.
It's a bit like embassies from the European Union
and it's internships actually that,
um,
as a result,
take place in other countries.
So that's too good.
And on top of that,
internships are also welcome
also one thousand two hundred euros.
Regarding application periods,
it's a little different,
Each delegation posts a little bit,
uh.
Her internship offer when she wants it.